Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm answering your Avengers: Infinity
War questions, plus revealing some more details
from the trailer you might have missed.
A brand new round of my Marvel giveaway is
also running here and to enter, you just need
to be a subscriber and comment about the movie
or leave a request for future Infinity War
videos.
Plus, I'll announce the winner from my trailer
breakdown later in this video.
Of course, speculation and possible spoilers
ahead for Infinity War and the MCU.
Let's kick things off with Iron Man and Clemence
who asks "Do you think the rumours of Iron
man using the Bleeding Edge armour are true?"
Well, yes, I do think the new armour we're
seeing hints of in the promos is very likely
the MCU's take on Iron Man's bleeding edge
armour.
In the Super Bowl spot, you could see the
new armor forming itself around Tony Stark
and I suspect it's coming from a new arc reactor
that Tony has designed.
The official Infinity War prelude comic shows
Tony playing around with a new blue reactor
in the Avengers Compound, as he prepares for
"the end of all things".
Iron Man's new blue reactor is a kind of easter
egg to the comic book bleeding edge armour
that first appeared in The Invincible Iron
Man.
In that comic book storyline, Iron Man's armour
flowed out of the arc reactor wrapping itself
around Tony Stark.
In the movie, the new armour will also probably
be a form of nano-technology, like Black Panther's
suit, although I think this is going to be
something Tony develops by himself and not
Wakandan tech.
As Lucifer points out, the way the thrusters
on Iron Man's feet morph into a single booster
may indicate nano tech at work which Tony
can command to form a variety of structures.
By the way, we haven't seen them in the trailers
yet, but the EW cover for Iron Man shows arm
wings or boosters which I think we'll also
see him use for additional control when he's
moving in space.
Next up, a lot of you want to know more about
the Black Order who we got to see a proper
team shot of in the new trailer.
In a change from the comics, in the MCU each
member of the Black Order is one of Thanos's
children, like Nebula and Gamora.
From left to right in this shot, we have Proxima
Midnight, Ebony Maw, Corvus Glaive and Cull
Obsidian, whose comic-book name was actually
Black Dwarf.
The Order were introduced as a team in the
Infinity comic book storyline where they were
sent to Earth by Thanos to retrieve the Infinity
Gems.
And it's now been confirmed that, in the Infinity
War movie, the Black Order come down to Earth
on a Q-ship, which is that circular alien
ship seen hovering over New York.
Indeed, in the first trailer, we already saw
Corvus Glaive attacking Vision for the Mind
Stone with his blade.
The weapon which Corvus Glaive wields in the
comics can cut through virtually anything
or anyone, which is why it's so terrifying
to see it used on Vision.
This scene likely takes place before Vision
is taken to Wakanda, so I think Vision is
likely saved at this point, although the way
Scarlet Witch looks at him later in Wakanda
makes me doubt he'll survive the film.
Back to the group shot of the Black Order
with Loki, some of you are wondering whether
Loki has switched sides again back to Thanos.
Judging by the way Proxima Midnight is pointing
her spear at the God of Mischief, I think
he's actually being summoned to Thanos to
answer for his failure in the first Avengers
movie, when he lost the Mind Stone that Thanos
gave him to help his takeover of Earth.
Now, we know that Loki has changed since then,
and although he's still got an eye for trouble,
I don't think he's going to switch sides again.
Loki may have already saved Bruce Banner by
using the Tesseract which he stole from Asgard
to portal him back to Earth to warn the other
Avengers about Thanos.
And Loki may even try to bargain with Thanos
offering up the Tesseract in exchange perhaps
for saving his brother, Thor's life.
Sadly though, I do think Loki's days are probably
numbered and Thanos will execute him after
he gives up the Space Stone.
Hopefully it will be a heroic death though.
There's also another interesting detail in
this shot with some fans pointing out that
there's a sword lying on the ground which
looks like it could be the Bifrost Sword that
Heimdall normally wields, though it's hard
to be sure from this image if the hilt is
exactly the same.
But if it is, then that's pretty bad news
for Heimdall as I suspect it means Thanos
or the Black Order killed him during their
attack on the Asgardian ship.
And if the theories about Heimdall having
the Soul Stone are correct, then this could
be how Thanos obtains that Stone.
But I'm going to talk more about the Soul
Stone later.
We do know that at least two characters survived
the attack on the Asgardian ship.
Bruce Banner ends up back on Earth and although
Thor gets his head squeezed like a grape by
Thanos, the God of Thunder survives this and
ends up with the Guardians.
But Ryan asked what the chances are of Thor
making it out alive by the end of the movie.
Well, my feeling right now is that it's about
50/50 for Thor.
The Russos recently said that Thanos and Thor
were the two characters who would get the
most screen time in Infinity War and we're
going to see Thor get some significant character
development in the movie.
As I mentioned in my last video, Thor's getting
a new hammer – and by the way, I think the
trailer's been digitally edited in this shot
to remove his new weapon so we can't see it
yet.
Thor's got his cape again here, plus there
are toys of Thor wielding his new weapon but
without his eyepatch, just a scar around his
damaged eye.
This all feels like Thor is going to be reborn
in a way.
He's getting a new weapon and his full eyesight
will be restored.
Now, all of these developments make me feel
it would be so cruel to watch the character
go through this and then just be killed by
the end of Infinity War.
So, I'm hoping Thor is one of the main Avengers
who survives through to Avengers 4.
A very intriguing detail some of you noticed
was that when Cap goes up against Thanos,
there's a little glint of yellow or perhaps
orange in his eyes.
Now, that might just be the reflection from
the Infinity Gauntlet, however, there's speculation
this might indicate that Cap is in possession
of or has the power of the Mind or the Soul
Stone.
It's possible that Steve Rogers has consumed
some of the Heart-Shaped Herb while in Wakanda.
There's a theory that, ultimately, the herb
gains its powers from the Soul Stone, which
was inside the meteorite that hit Wakanda,
meaning that the power of the Soul Stone could
have transferred to Cap.
And, yes, I know that Killmonger ordered the
destruction of the Heart-Shaped Herb in the
Black Panther movie, however, it's possible
somebody saved some or that there's more elsewhere
in the nation.
These are interesting possibilities though
there's no concrete evidence I can see from
the trailers so far, and it's quite possible
that the shot we see is simply Cap momentarily
holding his own against Thanos, before the
Mad Titan crushes him, which sadly he did
very easily in the Infinity Gauntlet comic.
By the way, throughout the promos we've seen
so far we've only ever seen Thanos with a
maximum of two Infinity Stones showing properly
in the gauntlet the power stone and the space
stone.
It's worth considering that Marvel might have
edited out other Infinity Stones from the
trailers to prevent spoiling exactly how many
Thanos has at different points in the movie,
in a similar way to how Thor's missing eye
in Ragnarok was restored in the trailers for
that film.
And talking of Infinity Stones, Roy Martin
Tandberg asks "What if the reason why Thanos
wants to wipe out half the universe is to
get the Soul Stone, by capturing their souls?"
Now, that's an interesting idea because so
far we've all mostly assumed that the Soul
Stone exists in some kind of physical form,
but what if it's actually something more ethereal?
I mean, in Thor: The Dark World when we were
introduced to the Aether, aka the Reality
Stone, it was a liquid-like substance that
took over Jane Foster's body.
"While the other relics often appear as stones,
the Aether is fluid and everchanging."
"It changes matter into dark matter."
"It seeks out host bodies, drawing strength
from their life-force."
And in the comics, the Soul Gem is something
that draws in souls which would fit with the
idea of Thanos capturing souls.
The Soul Gem also has its own internal world
called Soulworld where the souls live that
the gem has taken in.
And because these are comic book movies, capturing
a character's soul would be a convenient way
to appear to kill a character but have the
ability to bring them back when the remaining
Avengers presumably defeat Thanos in Avengers
4.
In fact, I actually think this might be what
happens to Gamora, Thanos's favourite daughter,
and I talked about that in my recent Death
Theory video.
But just where will the Soul Stone come into
play?
Well, now that we have more details about
Thanos's homeworld Titan, I think there's
a chance the Soul Stone location or discovery
will tie in with one of the action scenes
on Titan or perhaps Thanos's backstory even.
Other possibilities could be that the final
Infinity Stone is saved for a future movie
like Captain Marvel or Ant-Man and the Wasp,
and I talked about those possibilities in
my recent Soul Stone theory video.
Some of you also want to know whether the
comic book character Death will be in Infinity
War as she was an integral part of Thanos's
motivation in the comics.
Well, I'm almost sure this won't be the case.
Firstly, Marvel has gone with a different
motivation for Thanos which is related to
the tragedy that happened to his homeworld
Titan.
And secondly, I think Hela has potentially
taken the place of the Death character in
the MCU.
Hela is the Goddess of Death, after all, and
there's a possible hint that she knows or
has a back story with Thanos as she knew that
Odin's Infinity Gauntlet was fake.
In fact, I do think Hela could have survived
Ragnarok and might return in Infinity War
perhaps either in a post-credits scene or
maybe in Avengers 4 where she could team up
with Thanos.
If you want to know more about Hela's possible
return, I'll link to a video I made about
that in the description below.
Another character who hasn't appeared in any
of the main trailers is Nebula.
She did have a tiny appearance in the Super
Bowl TV spot, where she appeared looking angry
and brandishing her electroshock weapon on
Titan.
I'm hoping that as well as the film including
backstory for Gamora, we'll see more for Nebula
too.
As for what Nebula is up in the new movie,
in an interview, actress Karen Gillan has
said that Nebula gets a new and unexpected
BFF in Infinity War.
Gillan couldn't say who it was, but if it's
someone unexpected then I'm thinking she could
be paired up with someone more humorous like
Spider-Man, perhaps even Ant-Man?
Talking of Ant-Man, we haven't seen anything
at all of him or Hawkeye in the trailers or
promo images.
And I've got a separate video to explain where
they are plus who Game of Thrones star Peter
Dinklage will be playing in Infinity War.
I'll add a link here as soon as that video's
ready.
OK, question for you guys now: Who do you
think will survive Infinity War and why?
Let me know in the comments below, plus tell
me any requests for future Marvel videos.
You can also tweet me @Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
The winner from my Infinity War trailer breakdown
giveaway is on screen now.
If that's you, send me a private message with
your details and I'll get your prize out to
you.
If you liked this video, a thumbs-up is always
appreciated.
You can check out any of my other videos I
mentioned by tapping the screen for my Marvel
and theories playlists right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!